- WELCOME TO
PAPARD MATTRESS LIQUIDATORS.
HOW CAN I HELP YOU TODAY?
- I NEED TO BUY A NEW BED.
- OKAY.
YEAH, GOOD, GOOD.
YOU CAME TO THE RIGHT PLACE.
I'LL BE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO HELP YOU WITH THAT.
UH...
WHAT SIZE YOU NEED?
A FULL, QUEEN, KING?
- QUEEN.
- QUEEN, OH.
WE GOT A BIG SEL--
- AND JUST SO YOU KNOW,
IT NEEDS TO BE STURDY.
- ALL RIGHT.
- SHIT GETS KIND OF CRAZY
IN MY ROOM.
- OH, OKAY.
[laughs]
I GOT YOU, BROTHER.
I GOT YOU.
WELL, THIS POSTUREPEDIC MATTRESS
WE GOT RIGHT HERE,
THIS IS EXTREMELY COMFORTABLE
AND, UH...DURABLE.
- DO YOU MIND IF I TRY IT?
- NO, NOT AT ALL.
GO AHEAD.
I SHOULD ALSO MENTION, THERE'S
100% MONEY-BACK GUARANTEE ON--
- YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH!
WHO GOT THAT GOOD "D"?
I GOT THAT GOOD "D"!
YEAH!
NO, IT'S TOO HARD.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING SOFTER?
- UM...
OF COURSE.
THIS--THIS IS ONE OF OUR, UM,
NATURAL LATEX MATTRESSES.
IT'S ON SALE, TOO,
TODAY, AT $1,200.
- CAN I TRY IT?
- SURE.
- WHO GOT THAT GOOD "D"?
I GOT THAT GOOD "D"!
[grunting]
WHO GOT THAT GOOD "D"?
I GOT THAT GOOD "D"!
[grunts]
IT SEEMS A LITTLE PRICEY.
- OKAY.
NO, IT'S A LITTLE PRICEY.
I AIN'T GONNA LIE TO YOU.
BUT, UH, NO PROBLEM.
WE GOT OTHER CHOICES.
UM...
THIS A GREAT MEMORY
FOAM MATTRESS, RIGHT HERE.
IT'S A LITTLE CHEAPER, AND--
- CAN I TRY IT OUT?
- RIGHT.
RIGHT, YEAH.
I MEAN, OF COURSE,
OF COURSE YOU WANT TO TRY.
- YOU KNOW HOW IT GOES.
- YEAH.
OH, YEAH.
- COMING UP ON THEM LATE NIGHTS.
AYE! AYE!
BOOM, BOOM, BOOM, BOOM!
"YES!
SI, PAPI! SI, PAPI! SI, PAPI!"
- YEAH, MAN, RIGHT.
[laughs]
YEAH, MAN.
UM...
SEX HAPPENS.
- YIP!
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH!
WHO GOT THAT GOOD "D"?
I GOT THAT GOOD "D"!
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH!
WHO GOT THAT GOOD "D"?
I GOT THAT GOOD "D"!
OH!
OH, HERE IT COMES!
HERE IT COMES!
HOO-AH!
YUP, THAT'S THE ONE.
I'LL TAKE IT.
- OKAY, LET ME RING YOU UP.
- [grunting]
- AYE! AYE! AYE!
- WHO GOT THAT GOOD "D"?
I GOT THAT GOOD "D"!
[grunting]
- AYE, PAPI!
- WHO GOT THAT GOOD "D"?
I GOT THAT GOOD "D"!
[glass breaks]
- SI, PAPI!
- [grunting]
- AYE! AYE! AYE! AYE!
- WHO GOT THAT GOOD "D"?
I GOT THAT GOOD "D"!